you have one and it kind of quenches
your thirst you have two
and the bodies start to relax you have
tree
you start limbo you have four
and you start to snore
hi i'm ainsley harriet and this is snack
wars the uk
versus jamaica and this is lad bible
what have we got here stamina
conqueror jamaican roots tonic
yeah boy yeah man shake up your roots
what have we got in here donkey weed
green bark
brittle whisked and natural herbs
i could taste the donkey
well there's nothing better than a putty
or a
feels like a sausage roll better find
out i think i'm gonna go for the old
uh greg's first break
these patties are really lovely when
they
just come out the oven but down here at
lad bible they
pop them into the microwave it steams it
all
up and it becomes a little bit floppy
but the taste
spicy jamaica
you're looking good
no you're talking red stripe or uh
a li capita oil spectrum pen
well i'm not too sure about that i'm not
too sure but i am comparing it with
the red stripe
there's something really lovely about it
isn't there too it's just you know you
have one and it kind of quenches your
thirst you have two
and the bodies start to relax you have
tree
you start limbo you have four
and you start for slower
that has to be the winner right what
have we got here
yes sir a bitter bun gotta open this up
first eh
um it is good you need a little bit of
nutmeg grated on top sweeter
what we've got here now scones with
closet cream
and like any good chef i always come
with my own knife
no they do say it depends what
part of the country you come from
whether it's
the clotted cream first or
the jam yeah how do you like yours
just slap it on i know that's what i
mean
this is the winner and the winner is
what the [ __ ] is that
oh bro what that smells like [ __ ] ass
am i eating arse juice what is this
obviously i'm a man that tastes ah
so i know what ass tastes like this is
when you
you go in too deep i've never tried